though millions of Americans are already
sheltering in place to help slow the
spread the streets of San Francisco have
been largely empty since local officials
issued an order not to leave your home
unless absolutely necessary
similar scenes are playing out in cities
and towns all around the country
California's governor is also warning
that schools may be closed for the rest
of the school year the state of Kansas
has already made it official just two
weeks ago there were 126 reported corona
virus cases in 17 states here's where we
are now the virus has spread to all 50
states there are more than 6300 reported
cases and at least 109 people have died
New York State has the highest number of
reported cases bola Lengai is in a quiet
Times Square this morning mola do we
know if all the vigilance is actually
working well Anthony good morning I mean
just take a look around you know Times
Square typically day or night is a
tourist magnet packed with people but
now rules closing non-essential
businesses and limiting public
gatherings it seems to be having an
effect I mean look the streets are
pretty bare here compared to what they
usually are but without national
mandatory rules in place many states and
cities say they've been left on their
own to figure out how to combat this
virus Las Vegas is now a city without
sin the state's governor ordering all
non-essential businesses to shut down
leaving the lights on the strip but the
casinos bars and restaurants empty
meanwhile New York City saw the number
of coronavirus cases surged past 900
Tuesday up by more than 500 in just a
day and a half Mayor Bill DeBlasio
warned residents to be prepared to
shelter in place it has not happened yet
but it is definitely a possibility at
this point but New York Governor Andrew
Cuomo said not so fast no city in the
state can quarantine itself without
state approval still it's already a step
places like San Francisco have taken to
slow the spread of the virus that's
infected thousands of more people
in the US in a matter of days Tuesday a
Florida City leader announced three
deaths at a long-term care facility in
Fort Lauderdale and Illinois confirmed
that at least 18 residents and four
staff members tested positive at Chateau
nursing and rehabilitation center in the
town of Willowbrook the 22 cases who are
newly identified will have probably
anywhere between 50 and 90 individuals
that will have to contact the FAA
temporarily closed the air traffic
control tower at Chicago Midway
International Airport after several
technicians were infected and the
Brooklyn Nets confirmed that four of its
basketball players including NBA star
Kevin Durant tested positive the
nation's top infectious disease expert
Anthony pouchy says this will not be
over anytime soon it probably would be
several weeks and maybe longer before we
know whether we're having an effect to
help support the response the Pentagon
is giving five million respirator masks
and 2,000 ventilators to the Department
of Health and Human Services hospitals
across the nation have been scrambling
to make their medical supplies last our
first positive case last tuesday's since
then we've gone through almost six
months of supplies while businesses are
increasingly encouraging social
distancing uber and lyft had suspended
pool ride shares the PGA Golf
Championship has been postponed and
hotel giant Marriott is cutting employee
hours or just putting them on
temporarily the temporary leave the
demand for hotels guys just is not there
right now but if there is a silver
lining in this Tony Marriott says they
will continue to pay their employees
health benefits well that's something a
lot of people wondering just how long
this is all going to last molla thank
you very much